la citroën cx 2000 est la voiture de
l'année 49 journalistes spécialisés
représentant 14 pays d'europe l'ont
préféré aux autres voitures construites
en 1974 dans le mot le jury a tenu
compte dans son choix d'un grand nombre
de facteurs la sécurité le confort
l'économie la technologie général en un
mot les prestations d'ensemble des
voitures par rapport à leurs prix en
prenant la cx ils ont particulièrement
apprécié son aérodynamisme
exceptionnelle qui en fait une voiture
des temps modernes la cx va
progressivement se substituer aux idées
et ds dans la gamme citroën
après les spécialistes c'est maintenant
au public de juger cette voiture vendue
jusqu'à présent en france la cx sera
exportée en europe au cours des
prochaines semaines
elle coûte 27 mille francs
[Musique]